[Applause] what an atmosphere here at T-Mobile
Arena Chris Lee out there along with Wes mcau
our referees tonight gentlemen welcome to
the new NHL season this should be [Applause]
electric as a coach you're focused on the
the opponent at hand tonight but I think
we're all looking forward to taking a couple of
minutes to look back and then put it behind us
when the puck drops and get going try to do it
again and I'm looking forward to it just like
anybody [Music] [Applause] [Music] else St the
everybody say everybody say don't stop the [Music]
[Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
part down check
between the blue lines we got to manage
pucks right manage pucks make the right
decision with the puck angles if you can't
finish your check if you can great we want
to be physical if you can't take a good
angle don't let them beat you up the ice
into the good ice get to our game in
a hurry use everybody all playing the
same way Nick W your line will start
hagger petol and hilan nser going the
[Applause] first the Stanley Cup champions forming
up in the tunnel set to take the ice here at the
Fortress now welcome to the ice with the Stanley
Cup captain Mark [Applause] St all the amazing
shows you could see here in Las Vegas no
performance last year was better than that
of the golden knights they will celebrate
their Stanley Cup Championship tonight I
guess it's a memory now right just a great
memory some of the funnest hockey you know
we will'll ever play but it gives us a sense
of urgency right we want to be back there so
we know you're not going to be given to us first
touch got to get him moving against this court
Chuck up up stick yeah stop on it Michael here
Chandler Stevenson brings it across
out back door the first shot ends up
[Applause] behind I think they're almost
trying to go behind me and push me back
and then go through the middle so I'm going to
kind of be in between just let me know where to
[Music] up you're good higher higher higher
higher wheel wheel wheel wheel all cter sends
it in and he Carlson behind the net sweep one
out front good job by T who puts it in his own
neet t tried to carry it behind the cage PL it
towards the net and it TS in two nothing Vas
[Music]
good release good release he has him yeah
finished a moment ago tow drag between the
legs on net covered by grower good block good
block by there guy sometimes you got TI your
cap you know hey mnav skates on to it for the
golden knights oh beautiful uplet pass to barf
who moves in Hook from behind what a pass what a
finish three nothing Vegas how do you find look
for a stick there against this D here hey in the
corner it's thrown out in front that shot score
Jared mccan the 40 goal scorer from the last
season on the board on opening night as are the
Kraken as they try and fight their way back in
get it hey everyone be ready hey they're going
to play two they're going to play two line so
we keep our Pace up they're going to get tired
too right here right here right
here mangelo F that shot whistles
wide H by Chandler Stevenson eel for the empty net
SCS the crowd at the celebrates a banner raising
and the Stanley Cup to start and they celebrate
a 41 win on opening night definitely excited to
to start the year off uh we're fortunate
enough that we have mostly the same team
we've been through every situation and uh it
was just one of those uh games that a lot of
things went well for us it's pretty cool watching
a you know Championship Banner get raised into the
rafters and knowing that uh you know you're part
of history and it's going to be there forever it
was a pretty cool moment and um you know nice to
be there with the guys and and uh share that with
them